a local mother and daughter have made it
their mission to bring hospice patients
an extra special christmas patients
can't interact with volunteers or family
members like they normally would because
of covid19
so amber garcia and ayana castro stepped
in to offer some extra love
they've collected things like cards
blankets pajamas and fuzzy socks to give
to the 170 patients
at infinity hospice care with it being
covered with these people
not having their families we want to
make sure that they feel loved
even if it's just something as simple as
a blanket for them to know people are
thinking about you
we love you we can't be with you but hey
we're here
and those who work with hospice patients
say these gestures mean more than any of
us could ever know
nikki ellis of infinity hospice care
says isolation due to the pandemic
can be incredibly difficult video chats
are great
but being able to just hold their hand
or or just to sit
in the room with them is important but
that blanket is going to give them
warmth
right that blanket is going to just
remind them that
not only my family can't be here right
now
but just having this is just it's a
security thing
amber and ayanna are dropping all
donations at infinity hospice care this
friday
they still need twin sized sheets and
cards of course and fuzzy socks those
are always wanted to make the patients
smile
if you'd like to help we have more
information on our website
eightnewsnow.com